Auf dem mond ist eine riesige, höhle gefunden worden jetzt als idealer standort für eine mondstation
identifiziert wurde die auswertung der daten der mondsonde selene und der grail raumsonden
Und die verknüpfung der daten brachte wirklich erstaunliche ergebnisse, zu tage und diese welle bricht
sämtliche höhen rekorde hier auf der erde warum sie so außergewöhnlich ist und der perfekte standort für eine mondstation und
Absolut riesig wirklich riesig also wie ist die lage auf dem mond jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Der mode ist für den längeren aufenthalt von menschen eigentlich überhaupt nicht geeignet, er hat keine atmosphäre und verfügt auch nicht über ein magnetfeld
Astronauten und astronautinnen sind der kosmischen strahlung dort ungeschützt ausgesetzt zudem gibt es auf der oberfläche
extreme temperaturunterschiede zwischen tag und nacht ein absolut
unwirtlicher ort eine atmosphäre können wir dort nicht herstellen wir müssen eine luftdichte mondstation bauen allerdings
Könnten die astronauten auf verlauten vor den hohen temperaturen geschützt werden wenn die station
geschützt lege und auch die kosmische strahlung könnte von dem teams abgehalten werden wenn die station eben geschützt wäre und jetzt scheint der
ultimative schutz gefunden worden zu sein schon seit langem vermuten forschungsteams unter der mondoberfläche
lover sie entdeckten jetzt ein sogenanntes
skylight ein loch in einer
Höhlendecke durchmesser 50 meter es sieht aus wie ein krater ist es aber nicht sondern eben eine öffnung nach oben
In einer riesigen höhle eben ein skyler die japanische sonde selena hat sich jetzt entdeckt in der region marios hills
Im ozean der stürme stieß ich auf eine auffällige struktur unter der mondoberfläche
Das rada empfing ein doppeltes echo ein hohlraum unter der mondoberfläche war gefunden worden james von der pew university
Wertete daraufhin die schwerfällt daten der grail raumsonden der region aus und machte die sensation perfekt unter der mondoberfläche
Befindet sich eine. Höhle achtung festhalten mit einer länge von
50 kilometern höhe und einer breite von jeweils einem kilometer da passt
Die komplette großstadt rein und eine mondstation sowieso der absolute wahnsinn es wird spannend wie diese
Höhle jetzt erforscht wird und wie darin dann eine mondstation
Gebaut wird wenn er kein video zu diesem thema verpassen wollt und zu allen anderen themen dann drücken wir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke denn nur dann werdet ihr informiert wenn es ein neues video hier gibt und hier geht es weiter mit
Helium-3 abbau auf dem mond china als erster
Ich kann nur sagen der wettlauf zur besiedlung und der nutzung des mohns hat begonnen es bleibt spannend bis dann
bleibt dran